il attendait cela depuis près d'un mois
depuis ce samedi 28 novembre les
golfeurs peuvent de nouveau taper la
petite balle blanche sur les parcours
yvelinois ils étaient des centaines sont
des greens une affluence record au golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
jarret prend les airs et on sent bien
après avoir joué ben on était ravi de
voir que le bleu gaulle faisait partie
des premières activités outdoor qui
pouvaient réouvrir donc à la fois hier
et aujourd'hui on est venu profiter
on a la chance d'avoir un très beau
temps en plus ce week-end pour neak
rogen gens consultent les week-ends et
on attendait l'ouverture avec impatience
en plus il faisait bout donc c'est un
vrai bonheur de venir jouer hier et
aujourd'hui pour respecter les règles
sanitaires de ce second déconfinement le
protocole est toujours renforcer les
râteaux des bunkers sont retirés les
golfeurs ne doivent pas toucher le
drapeau du gel hydroalcoolique et
distribuer les parcours ont également
été raccourcie pour coller à la règle
des 20 km pendant une durée de 3 heures
maximum
on a divisé nos parcours pour en faire
des parcours 9 trous il ya qu'un seul
parcours qui n'a pas été touché par ça
c'est le parcours de l'oise et qui est
restée sept trous mais effectivement on
a la chance de pouvoir dispatcher faire
des parcours composite avec neuf trous
et sept trous de golf national neuf
trous en moins de trois heures une
mesure qui n'enthousiasme pas les
pratiquants on n'a pas le choix donc
c'est vrai que l'après midi on va faire
un peu trop active pour compenser et
puis même à neuf trous malgré tout c'est
déjà ça donc
en a le temps de s'appliquer
et ça suffit personnellement je pense
que on peut largement faire plus
maintenant pour commencer pourquoi pas
les golfs yvelinois espère désormais le
feu vert des autorités pour pouvoir
rouvrir l'intégralité des parcours
le retour à la normale pourrait être
programmée le 15 décembre